and from thence Chinggis Khaan proceeded
to Baqarah and in the beginning of
Muharram he camped for the gates of the
Citadel
and his troops were more numerous than
ants or locusts being in their multitude
beyond estimation or computation
detachment after detachment arrived each
like a billowing sea and encamped round
about the town at sunrise 20,000 men
from the Sultan's auxilary army issued
force from the Citadel together with
most of the inhabitants being commanded
by [ __ ] can [ __ ] clan was said to be a
Mongol and to have fled from Chinggis
Khaan and joined the Sultan when these
forces reached the banks of the Oxus the
patrols and advance parties of the
Mongol army fell upon them left no trace
of them
[Music]
on the following day went from the
reflection of the Sun the plane seemed
to be a tray filled with blood the
people of bukhara opened their gates and
closed the door of strife and battle the
Imams and notables came on a deputation
to Chinggis Khaan who entered to inspect
the town and the citadel he rode into
the friday mosque and pulled up before
the max hora whereupon his son thali
dismounted and ascended the pulpit
Chinggis Khaan asked those present
whether this was the palace of the
Sultan they replied that it was the
house of God then he too got down from
his horse and mounting two or three
steps of the pulpit he exclaimed the
countryside is empty of fodder fill our
horses bellies whereupon they opened all
the magazine's in the town and began
carrying off the grain and they brought
the cases in which the qur'an's were
kept out into the courtyard of the
mosque where they cast the qur'an's left
and right and turned the cases into
Manges for their horses after which they
circulated cups of wine and sent for the
singing girls of the town to sing and
dance for them while the Mongols raised
their voices to the tunes of their own
songs
[Music]
when Chinggis Khaan left the town he
went to the festival masala and mounted
the pulpit and the people having been
assembled he asked which were the
wealthy among them 280 persons were
designated a hundred and ninety of them
being natives of the town and the rest
strangers he then began a speech in
which after describing the resistance
and treachery of the Sultan he addressed
them as follows o people know that you
have committed great sins and that the
great ones among you have committed
these sins if you ask me what proof I
have for these words I say it is because
I am the punishment of God if you had
not committed great sins God would not
have sent a punishment
like me upon you
[Music]
for some years I continued averse from
mentioning this event deeming it so
horrible that I shrank from recording it
and ever withdrawing one foot as I
advanced the other to whom indeed can it
be easy to write the announcement of the
death blow of Islam and the Muslims or
who is he on whom the remembrance
thereof can weigh lightly Oh would that
my mother has not borne me or that I had
died and become a forgotten thing air
this befell yet with all the number of
my friends urged me to set it down in
writing I say therefore that this thing
involves the description of the greatest
catastrophe and the most dire calamity
which befell all men generally and the
Muslims in particular for even
Antichrist will spare such as follow him
though he destroy those who oppose him
but these Tatars spared none slaying
women and men and children killing
unborn babies for these were people who
emerged from the confines of China and
attacked the cities of Turkestan like
kashgar and and Vala según and then
advanced on the cities of transoxiana
such as Samarkand bukhara and the like
taking possession of them and treating
their inhabitants in such wise as we
shall mention all this they did in the
briefest space of time remaining only
for so long as their March required and
no more moreover they need no
commissariat nor the conveyance of
supplies for they have with them sheep
cows horses and and the like quadrupeds
the flesh of which they eat nor tells as
for their beasts which they ride these
dig into the earth with their hooves and
eat the roots of plants knowing naught
of barley and so when they are liked
anywhere they have need of nothing from
without
as for their religion they worship the
Sun when it rises and regard nothing as
unlawful stories have been related to me
which the hero can scarcely credit as to
the terror of the Tatars which God
Almighty cast into men's hearts so that
it is said that a single one of them
would enter a village or a quarter
wherein there were many people and would
continue to slay them one after another
none daring to stretch forth his hand
against this horsemen and I've heard
that one of them took a man captive but
had not with him any weapon wherewith to
kill him and he said to his prisoner
lay a head on the ground and do not move
and he did so and the Tartar went and
fetched his sword and and slew him
therewith
[Music]
now Hulagu commanded all those subject
to him to go against the Tajik capital
Baghdad which was the seat of the Tajik
Dominion the king who sat in Baghdad was
not called Sultan or Melek as the
Turkish Iranian or Kurdish autocrats
customarily are but caliphs that is a
descendant of Muhammad the great Hulagu
went against the Caliph with a countless
multitude composed of all the peoples
subject to him this was done in the
autumn and winter seasons because of the
severe heat of that country in the
summer prior to his departure he ordered
by Juno yin and the troops with him in
the land of the Sultan of rum to go and
surround the Great Tigris River on which
the city of Baghdad was built so that no
one could flee by boat from the city or
to the more secure Basra they
immediately obeyed the command tying
pontoon bridges across the Great River
and sinking between the river and its
bed sturdy fences with iron hooks and
pipes so that no one could depart the
city swimming without them knowing about
it
now the caliph who resided in the city
proudly and presumptuously sent many
troops against those guarding the river
they were under the command of a chief
named da ba da austere can of his house
da ba da went and first triumphed
killing some 3,000 Tatars when evening
fell he sat eating and drinking without
a care and he sent messages to the
Khalif saying I defeated all of them and
tomorrow I will do away with the few
survivors
now the crafty and ingenious tartar army
spent the entire night arming and
organizing they surrounded the Tajik
army a daybreak they put their swords to
work destroying the entire group and
throwing them into the river only a few
men escaped that same morning the great
Hulagu surrounded the city of Baghdad
stationing everyone at arm's length from
the wall and telling them to demolish it
and guard well that no one escaped he
sent valiant emissaries to the Caliph so
that he would come out obediently and
pay taxes to the Khan the Caliph gave a
stern reply full of insults claiming to
be Lord of sea on land you were a dog a
Turk why should I pay taxes to you or
obey you
however Hulagu did not become aggrieved
because of the insults nor did he write
any boasts he merely said God knows what
he does then he ordered the wall
demolished and they demolished it he
said to rebuild it again and guard it
carefully and they did so the city was
full of soldiers and people for seven
days they stood on the walls but no one
shot arrows at them nor were swords used
either by the citizens or by the Tartar
soldiers but after seven days the
citizens began to request peace and to
come to Hulagu with affection and
submission and Hulagu ordered that this
be done that peace be made then
countless multitude came through the
city gates climbing over each other to
see who would reach him first Hulagu
divided up among the soldiers those who
came out and ordered the soldiers to
take them far from the city and to kill
them secretly so that the others would
not know
they killed all of them four days later
the Khalif also emerged with his two
sons with all the grand ease and much
gold silver and precious stones as
fitting gifts for Hulagu and his Nobles
but first Hulagu honored him reproaching
him for dallying and not coming to him
quickly but then he asked the Caliph
what are you God or man and the Caliph
responded I am a man and the servant of
God Hulagu asked well did God tell you
to insult me and to call me a dog and to
not give food and drink to God's dog now
in hunger the dog of God shall devour
you and he killed him with his own hands
that he said is an honour for you
because I killed you myself and did not
give you to another for killing he
ordered his own son to slay one of the
caliphs sons while he gave the other son
as a sacrifice to the Tigris River
saying it did not harm us but was our
collaborator in killing the senseless
ones Hulagu then ordered the troops
guarding the walls to descend and kill
the inhabitants of the city great and
small
the Mongols organized as though
harvesting a field and cut down
countless innumerable multitude of men
women and children for forty days they
did not stop then they grew weary and
stopped killing their hands grew tired
they took the others for sale
they destroyed mercilessly
Hulagu ordered all his soldiers to take
the goods and property over the city
they all loaded up with gold silver
precious stones pearls and costly
garments for it was an extremely rich
city unequaled on earth
[Music]
you